I talk about the Olympics I wasn't being
patriotic I was just killing time no
this big big story proud time for
America yeah yesterday Michael Phelps
set an all-time all-time Olympic record
for most metals you got to give it up
Jeff Phelps has so much gold on his
chest he's been asked to join the cast
of Jersey Shore he's gonna slide right
in as one of the guys
he'll need a little better tan yeah yeah
a little more hair on his body did you
heard this big scandal eight female
badminton players were expelled from the
Olympics for trying to lose on purpose
did you hear about that yeah so
tragically they'll never have another
chance to play badminton unless they get
invited to a picnic I'm sorry
it's just a sport other sports have more
of my respect and suffering
I actually was watching badminton today
and there was it was the men's singles
and a coach came out in like workout
gear
why does a badminton coach wear workout
gear plenty of things for you to be
angry about it this Olympics and II well
I I like to just watch the live feed of
the events that cares about yeah no
seriously the other the Olympic
badminton players were apparently trying
to lose on purpose this is a big story
but really think about it if you've
trained day and night for four years to
be in the Olympics for badminton in a
way haven't you already lost
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm sorry in all fairness that's how I
play it a lot of my anger about the
sport is how I played it as a kid on the
tough streets of Brookline Mass I was in
a gang a bad betting gang you better
watch out
I'll get you with my shuttlecock yeah
nice ring to it us swimming star Ryan
Lochte has sparked a big controversy by
worrying a grill designed by a rapper
yeah yeah not only that Lochte times his
races with a big clock around his neck
he got it from Flavor Flav explaining
the reference the US team you shut up
pal I love it I hired a guy to laugh at
me wasn't the original understand and
I've kind of let it know you've adapted
it right where's my chick thanks a lot
that orange haired freak hey this is
good news gang the US team has swept all
the medals in this skeet shooting event
yeah so despite our bad economy it's
nice to know our country has never been
safer from an invasion of Skeets I don't
even know what really what they call it
a speed or what it is I do all their
little clay disks but I don't know why
they're called the skete nope neither do
ye thanks for being here though and just
laugh at me and will I have no idea but
I find you absurd Conan hey let's change
topics now enough about the Olympics oh
yeah
screw them yeah this network ain't
airing it big political upset in Texas
did hear about this in Texas a tea party
candidate who's Hispanic has won the
Republican Senate nomination yeah his
campaign slogan is I hate me
he said promise if elected I'll have
myself deported hey what else is going
on not everybody happy about you know
some of the Obamacare provisions are
ready to take effect and one of them is
free birth control for women not
everybody's happy yeah not everybody
happy though a House Republican has
compared the new law requiring free
birth control for women to Pearl Harbor
yeah when asked to clarify he said both
involve unplanned early morning
invasions I accept this award for that
joke thank you